if if they went to the men and said you
evil men one woman for life do you know
who would break it first freaking women
women women women women women women go
go to any Rock concert do you know who's
throwing themel it's not the the evil
men the evil men at Drake's concert just
Drake's going out and saying women
please sleep with me no it's the women
it's the women saying please please take
us take us please and it's like like the
tradcons they'll say oh but she was just
young she didn't know what she was doing
and then you'll look at like a
18-year-old chick or 19-year-old chick
and she's like I want to do that one
please take me please oh
please I just can't I can't deal with
the simpery